foreign
do you have a desire to move your
existing applications to the cloud but
are unsure where to start which
applications are suitable for migration
where should I run them how much effort
will it take if so this video is for you
hi I'm Mike Coleman a developer Advocate
at Google cloud and today I'd like to
talk to you about how to assess and plan
migrating and modernizing your existing
applications running on either VMware or
other public clouds onto Google Cloud
platform
one of the first steps when migrating to
any Cloud platform is to assess your
existing inventory and then plan your
migration strategy this strategy may
vary depending on the business
criticality of the application or the
complexity and the effort required to
migrate or modernize the targeted
workloads
in the end you have a number of options
when it comes to relocating existing
apps including re-hosting re-platforming
or refactoring but how can you make the
right decision and apply the right
strategy
in this video we're going to take a look
at how you can use Google Cloud's fit
assessment tool to help speed the
planning of your application's Cloud
migration Journey today customers are
facing a number of challenges when it
comes to planning and executing the
right strategy to migrate their existing
VMS from their on-prem environment to
the cloud these challenges include
amongst other things the lack of factual
and accurate information on which VMS
can be moved and which ones can be
modernized and what is the required
effort to do so
if companies do have any intelligence
around these issues it's oftentimes
managed using ad hoc spreadsheets or
Discovery tools which were purpose built
to indiscriminately discover all your
infrastructure and are lacking the
know-how of what is required to
successfully modernize existing VMS
when migrating to Google Cloud you can
leverage our migration fit assessment
tool to guide you through your migration
journey to have a clear understanding on
which VMS are best suited for migration
and which ones could benefit from
further modernization the assessment
tool can be used to discover and collect
the necessary information from your VMS
and then assess the possible migration
Journeys for each of those VMS once the
VMS have been assessed you can generate
two kinds of reports a summary report
which gives you an executive summary and
a high level overview of how many VMS
can be migrated to Google Cloud VMware
engine or Google compute engine and how
many VMS can be further modernized and
refactored to run in containers
the second report is a complete report
showing you all the rules that were
assessed on each of the VMS and a
prescriptive guidance on what needs to
be done to make them applicable for each
of the migration Journeys now let's take
a look at the summary report and the
immediate insights that it brings to you
let's look at the first section of the
report this section gives you an
executive summary of your current VM
landscape an aggregated view of the
resources used such as CPU memory and
storage and how your existing VMS map to
gcp's VM offerings it also shows you
what percentage of your existing VMS can
be migrated using a lift and shift
strategy at a low effort cost and what
percentage are ripe for a higher value
modernization effort meaning
containerizing and running on kubernetes
or serverless
this executive summary alone gives you
the factual information that is needed
to start planning how your migration
strategy might look
now let's dive deeper into what these
Journeys mean
in this section of the report you can
see the lift and shift Journeys and the
top technical blockers for each of them
the two lift and shift Journeys are
migrating VMS to Google compute engine
and migrating VMS to Google Cloud VMware
engine or gcve
gcve is a Google Cloud managed service
for running VMware on gcp it's the
simplest migration journey in terms of
effort but costs a bit more than simply
running those workloads on Google
compute engine
now let's jump into the next section of
the report the refactor to Containers
analysis in the refactor to Containers
analysis section you can see how many
applications were discovered and their
classification into the three kinds of
supported containers Linux tomcat and
IIs
and how many of them are fit for
containerization then in the bottom
section you can see which Target
environments are applicable for the
discovered applications once
containerized
these Target environments might be
anthos clusters gke standard mode
clusters gke autopilot clusters or Cloud
run
let's move on to the next section of the
report
in this section you can see an overview
of the on-prem modernization journeys
on-prem Journeys include shifting a VM
to an anthos on bare metal cluster or
attaching a VM to an anthos on bare
metal cluster by attaching your existing
VMS to the anthos control plane you can
apply consistent security and policy
monitor the health and performance of
your services and manage traffic for
both VMS and containers or alternatively
shift your VMS as is to run on anthos VM
runtime
anthos VM runtime uses Cube vert to
orchestrate VMS on anthos clusters
allowing you to work with your VM based
apps and workloads in a uniform
development environment
this section gives you visibility into
how many of your VMS will fit into each
of these Journeys as well as the top
blockers from here we can scroll down to
the last part of the summary report in
this part you can see a prescriptive
guide for two modernization strategies
the first on the left shows what can be
achieved in a shorter time frame and a
low effort versus a high modernization
and high value strategy on the right
to summarize what we've seen so far the
fit assessment summary report gives you
a high level overview of the different
modernization strategies which is based
on actual data collected from your
environment which reduces uncertainties
around planning your modernization
journey
now let's dive deeper into the full
report and examine one of the VMS
let's take a look at this VM for example
if you expand to see more details you
can see how much effort will be required
for each of the migration Journeys
now let's take a closer look at the
Tomcat app container journey and see why
a minimal effort is required to
containerize it
the report shows you all the rules that
were assessed for this journey and if
some effort is required it gives you the
actual steps that will have to be taken
to remediate the issue
in the same manner if you click on one
of the no fit Journeys you can see why
that VM is not fit for migration
with this full report you can start
planning the migration strategy for each
of your VMS and have a recipe for the
steps that will have to be taken if
needed to migrate those VMS
now let's talk a little bit about how
you actually use the fit assessment tool
the fit assessment tool is comprised of
a single binary mfit and a couple of
scripts the mfit binary is installed on
any Linux workstation in your
environment the best way to think of the
Linux workstation is that it acts like
the assessment engine Gathering high
level information about your environment
as well as processing output from those
scripts I just mentioned it's important
to note that mfit doesn't require an
internet connection and doesn't upload
any of the information into Google Cloud
the actual fit assessment is a
three-step process the first step is to
run an inventory discovery of your VM
landscape
this is done using the mfit Discover
vsphere command from the Linux
workstation this command can discover
your entire vsphere environment or can
be scoped to a folder cluster or data
center
the second step is the collection step
in this step you run the collection
script A bash script for Linux or a
Powershell script for Windows on the VM
you would like to assess and then import
the script's output and then import the
data using the mfit Discover import
command
then you get to the last step where you
generate the reports as mentioned
previously you can generate both a
summary report and a full report using
the command mfit report
these reports can be generated into HTML
Json and CSV formats which you can
either view locally on your browser or
import into Google Cloud console or use
as an input to other systems in machine
readable formats
I hope this video showed you how Google
Cloud's fit assessment tool can help you
assess and plan your Cloud migration
Journey for more detailed information
check out our documentation as well as
other videos in our migrate series and
don't forget to like And subscribe to be
alerted whenever we publish new content
foreign
[Music]
[Music]